In 1983, Paul Mockapetris proposed a distributed
database of internet name and address pairs,
now known as the Domain Name System (DNS).
This is essentially a distributed “phone
book” linking a domain’s name to its address,
allowing you to type in something like todayifoundout.com
instead of the IP address of the website.
The distributed version of this system allowed
for a decentralized approach to this “phone
book.”
Previous to this, a central HOSTS.TXT file
was maintained at Stanford Research Institute
that then could be downloaded and used by
other systems.
Even by 1983, this was becoming a problem
to maintain, which ultimately led to the Domain
Name System.
In these Wild West days of the internet when
domain names first began to be registered
for commercial use, with symbolics.com kicking
things off when it was registered to Symbolics
Computer Corp. on March 15, 1985, few people
had any idea how big the internet was going
to be in the coming decades.
As a result, the value of domain names was
underestimated to an almost comical degree.
Examples of domain names that were snapped
up in the halcyon days of the early 1990s
by savvy internet denizens include Beer.com,
(sold in 2004 for $7 million), Hotel.com (sold
in 2011 for $11 million) and the subject of
today’s article- Sex.com.
This particular domain was registered by one
Gary Kremen for free thanks to the National
Science Foundation footing the bill at the
time.
While Kremen has run or invested in a myriad
of successful businesses since, he is perhaps
best known today as the creator of Match.com,
which presently brings in a few hundred million
dollars per year.
Although, funny enough, owing to his removal
as CEO by an amazingly inept board who likewise
demonstrated a spectacular lack of vision
and undervaluation of the website, Match.com
was sold for a mere $7 million in 1998 (about
$10.7 million in today’s dollars), with
Kremen only getting about $50,000 of that
for his idea and effort in building the site.
(A little over a year later it sold again
for about $50 million with little changes
to the site in the interim, with Kremen noting
of the previous sale that he vehemently argued
against, “Talk about mispricing.”)
But we’re not here to talk about Match.com.
Rewinding back to 1994, Kremen, a holder of
bachelor’s degrees in computer science and
another in electrical engineering, as well
as an MBA from Stanford Business School, saw
great potential in online businesses, and
thus had made a practice of snapping up domains
that he thought would work great for various
e-businesses he had ideas for.
So when he noticed sex.com was available,
he nabbed it via the registrar Internic, which
was later acquired by Network Solutions.
Of course, at the time, himself having long
struggled to find a steady girlfriend, Kremen
was busy attempting to give the world of dating
a major upgrade via introducing the aforementioned
online dating service, match.com, so set aside
sex.com to do something with later.
Important here is that when Kremen did register
sex.com, while he named his non-incorporated
company Online Classifieds as the owner of
the domain, he put himself as the sole point
of contact.
Seemingly, this should have made it pretty
difficult for someone to steal sex.com from
him, but at the time, as noted, few people
had any real notion that domains should have
value, even, as it turns out, Network Solutions.
In fact, at least according to their later
legal argument in a case with Kremen, they
stated they considered domains more like phone
numbers than property someone owned.
Enter Stephen Cohen.
Besides supposedly having a Juris Doctor degree
from Southern California Law School, over
the course of his life Cohen’s been involved
in a shockingly high number of schemes.
For example, according to a lawyer friend
of his, one Roger Agajanian, Cohen even once
successfully impersonating a judge in Colorado
for several years, including, to quote, “[letting]
people off all the time” while acting as
a judge.
While he was arrested countless times over
the years for his many exploits, he was particularly
adept at not only staying out of jail, but
also weaseling out of actually coughing up
any money to people he’d defrauded and creditors
via, according to Agajanian, “playing procedural
games” and hiding acquired assets until
those he’d conned just gave up trying to
get anything out of him.
Fast-forwarding a bit to the late 1980s, and
an Orange Country sheriff, Gary Jones, had
been trying to catch Cohen at something for
years, ever since discovering he’d been
stealing expensive cars from people via pretending
to impound them when the people fell behind
on payments, as well as operating a phony
law firm.
During the ordeal, Cohen even allegedly had
the audacity to threaten Sheriff Jones’
family if he didn’t back off, which, to
quote Jones, “made it personal, so every
time that guy sneezed, I knew.”
But even under such close scrutiny, he still
seemingly had little trouble keeping up his
various illegal activities.
But in 1991, the master conman finally had
a stint in prison, at the Federal Correctional
Institution, Lompoc, in California, for his
involvement in a bankruptcy fraud scheme,
where, among other duplicitous activities,
he brazenly posed as a variety of different
lawyers in the case.
We could go on for pages on the various fascinating
activities Cohen got up to over the decades
as he mastered the craft of being not only
a conman but also someone who seemingly could
give the world’s top lawyers a lesson in
how to exploit the U.S. legal system to get
away with almost anything, but today we’re
just going to focus on one of his little escapades-
the sex.com heist.
On February 1, 1995, Cohen was released from
prison.
Seemingly not long after, he set his sites
on acquiring sex.com.
Rather than make an offer to the rightful
owner, Kremen, to buy it or even create a
partnership of some sort (which actually might
have really worked out for both Cohen and
Kremen, as it turns out), he seems to have
decided he’d rather just steal it.
To do so, he settled on an ingeniously simple
plan, which he put into motion on October
15, 1995.
Cohen began by forging a letter from the president
of Kremen’s Online Classifieds, Sharon Dimmick.
Using a fake, seemingly official looking letterhead,
in the letter Dimmick, on behalf of Online
Classifieds, noted that Kremen had been fired
and that they were “relinquishing” all
rights to Sex.com to Cohen.
Moreover, in the letter, it stated that:
“Because we do not have a direct connection
to the internet, we request that you notify
the internet registration  on our behalf,
to delete our domain name sex.com.
Further, we have no objections to your use
of the domain name sexcom and this letter
shall serve as our authorization to the internet
registration to transfer sex.com to your corporation.”
Of course, Sharon Dimmick didn’t exist,
but that didn’t matter here.
When Cohen presented the letter to Network
Solutions, the latter, with remarkable credulity
(particularly given that a company with “online”
in their name wouldn’t have access to the
internet, even in 1995), transferred the domain
to Cohen’s company, Sporting Houses Management,
just two days later on October 17th, without
ever bothering to even try to contact the
one person who actually was listed as a contact
and had registered the domain in the first
place- Gary Kremen.
Kremen would later note that on October 18,
“I woke up… and it was gone…
It’s like someone forging the title to your
house and then taking it over.”
Naturally, he contacted Network Solutions
to ask what had happened and to get the domain
back, noting that he’d never authorized
any such transfer, but they claimed they had
an internal policy to not get involved in
any dispute about ownership of domains and
refused to transfer it back.
(Presumably he’d have had much better luck
if he just wrote them a letter on Cohen’s
behalf telling them to transfer the domain
back…)
Of course, Cohen wasn’t about to give up
his new asset, leaving Kremen no alternative
but to sue and try to get the courts to make
him.
Beyond initially not being sure if he wanted
to so publicly associate himself with online
porn via suing Cohen for sex.com back, the
other problem was that Kremen knew the legal
battle would be extremely expensive and he
didn’t have the money at the time to pursue
the case.
So he put it on the backburner for a while.
On top of this, when Kremen later began seriously
looking into suing, he was contacted by a
lawyer from the Patent and Trademark Office.
Said lawyer advised him that suing Cohen would
be a pointless act because Cohen had trademarked
sex.com, retroactive to 1979 when Cohen had
first started using the term, meaning that
thanks to that trademark, there was almost
no chance Kremen would win, even if he had
been the one who’d originally registered
sex.com.
If you’re now wondering how Cohen could
have been using sex.com all the way back in
the late 1970s, he claimed on his trademark
application that he had been running an electronic
bulletin board called The French Connection
back in 1979, which was, to quote, a board
for “swingers, nudist camps, and alternative
lifestyles.”
Essentially a hookup electronic bulletin board
and where sex.com, supposedly short for Sex
Communications, was being used by Cohen.
Cohen would later claim, “It was a very,
very lucrative business.
It’s what became Sex.com today.”
It is known that Cohen really did once run
such an electronic bulletin board service
and later a real-world swingers meeting place
in Orange County in the late 1980s called
“The Club”.
This is definitively known, among other reasons,
because in 1990 Cohen was arrested for operating
such a sex club in a residential zone, though
was later somehow found not guilty by a jury.
As to whether “sex.com” ever had anything
to do with any of this, it’s generally thought
unlikely.
Whatever the case, according to Kremen, while
Cohen really did file for such a trademark
once he acquired sex.com, it would later turn
out that the Patent and Trademark Office lawyer
Kremen had been discussing the matter with
and who for a time successfully dissuaded
him from attempting the lawsuit was none other
than the conman who’d stolen sex.com in
the first place- Stephen Cohen.
In any event, Kremen did not initial pursue
legal action and in the interim Cohen attempted
to create the “Caesar’s Palace of brothels”
and even a fantasy sex island with sex.com
being the web presence for these business
ideas.
But all such plans fell through, and he simply
began offering subscription porn on sex.com,
as well as running very lucrative ads as well.
On top of that, even though he’d not actually
been granted the trademark for sex.com, he
nonetheless began suing everyone using related
terms in their brands and the like.
As Cohen put it in an interview, “We’ve
got lawsuits filed left and right for trademark
infringement.
We’re constantly filing new lawsuits.
Constantly.
We have teams of lawyers at Ocean Fund who
do nothing but file lawsuits.”
(This seemingly actually was lucrative in
its own right, with some website owners at
the time simply choosing to take a deal instead
of pay all the legal fees needed to take the
matter to court.)
Speaking of Ocean Fund, around this same time,
Cohen sold sex.com to a company called Sand
Man Internacional in Mexico, a subsidiary
of Ocean Fund International, based in the
British Virgin Islands.
Naturally, though the paper trail is surprisingly
difficult to follow, presumably by design,
it would appear this was all just a way for
Cohen to move ownership of the domain to an
entity, which he owned, based outside of the
United States.
However, Cohen’s lawsuits here would be
the beginning of his undoing in the sex.com
heist.
You see, while Kremen couldn’t afford to
go after Cohen himself, Cohen was making himself
a lot of enemies in the world of online porn-
some of which agreed to team up with Kremen
to cover legal costs of getting the sex.com
domain taken away from Cohen.
And so it was that in the summer of 1998,
Kremen finally decided to sue to get the domain
back.
Soon enough, however, many of the porn moguls
that agreed to go into the battle with Kremen
abandoned the cause, but one lawyer, Charles
Carreon, decided to stick it out with Kremen,
despite Kremen’s lack of ability to pay.
Later, when Cohen sued Kremen for defamation,
Carreon had the bright idea to leverage certain
terms in Kremen’s home owners insurance
plan with State Farm to obligate them to defend
Kremen in the defamation case.
With State Farm’s large team of crack lawyers
now on his side, the runaround Cohen was giving
the court system began to fall apart.
Around the same time, Kremen stated he was
able to “liquidate the dot-com stock I had
and put it all on red to beat [Cohen]”.
At this point, it was personal, no doubt partially
fueled by the fact that apparently Cohen had
a fun little habit of randomly calling Kremen
to taunt him or otherwise just mess with him
in a variety of ways.
Cohen didn’t help himself later when he
was caught on camera posing as one of Kremen’s
lawyers and stealing 113 pages of his own
bank records that Kremen’s legal team had
uncovered, which, by the way, apparently included
definitive records of him transferring some
$25 million made from sex.com offshore- and
this was just a portion of what he probably
actually made.
When this theft was revealed, for the first
time, the court system started considering
that maybe the smart looking, smooth talking,
Network Solutions backed Cohen wasn’t the
upstanding businessman he appeared to be and
the eccentric, socially awkward Kremen, who
looked pretty much as you’d expect a stereotypical
middle aged computer nerd in the 1990s to
look, might actually not be crazy.
But while this court battle was being waged,
as you might have guessed from that $25 million
figure previously stated, Cohen was making
the most of his stolen property- at its peak,
according to Cohen- so take this with a huge
grain of salt- earnings were around $225 million
per year thanks to having about 9 million
subscribers paying $25 a pop, plus additional
revenues from advertising, which he claimed
brought in about $1 million per month.
As Cohen once bragged in an interview, “Let
me make it real simple for you.
Our audience is not America.
It’s the whole world.
There’s only one word in the whole world
that everyone understands – sex.
You type the word ‘sex,’ you come to Sex.com.”
Of course, Cohen could have been making up
these fantastical sums, but based on estimated
traffic at the time, which included somewhere
in the vicinity of 140 to 700 million page
views per month at its peak, and revenues
that Kremen would later receive in ads when
he got sex.com back, it’s generally thought
Cohen made around $100 million from sex.com
in the five years he controlled the domain,
though given his absolute refusal to share
such financial records with the courts, even
when ordered, it’s difficult to say for
sure.
Whatever his real earnings, being well versed
in the law and able to afford the best lawyers
to boot, Cohen successfully dragged out the
case for two years, making a variety of arguments
such as that because Kremen’s Online Classifieds
was not an officially registered company at
the time he listed it as such when acquiring
sex.com, it could not have possibly ever owned
sex.com.
One of Cohen’s lawyer’s added to this,
“Thus, Online Classifieds’ allegation
that it was the owner of the Sex.com URL has
no basis in fact and is tantamount to perpetrating
a fraud.”
Yes, they brazenly accused Kremen of fraud
in the case…
Finally, in November of 2000, the courts ordered
that the ownership of sex.com should revert
back to Kremen and that Cohen owed Kremen
a total of $40 million of the then estimated
$100 million in revenue Cohen had supposedly
made in the five years he had possessed sex.com.
Further, the court added in an additional
$25 million punitive damage award, bringing
the total owed to Kremen to $65 million.
Naturally, Cohen had no interest in paying
a dime to Kremen.
Although the district court “froze” Cohen’s
known assets (read: issued an order on paper),
this seems to have posed little impediment
to Cohen who had seemingly already planned
ahead for such a contingency.
Beyond leaving the country, he’d already
wired everything liquid to a variety of accounts
offshore and even stripped his real estate,
which would soon be awarded to Kremen after
another extended court battle, of everything
of value (including doors and toilets).
Later the mansion was vandalized directly
before Kremen was to take possession of it,
with it generally thought Cohen was behind
that.
As to why Cohen officially claimed he could
not pay anything to Kremen, despite having
made a boatload of money off of sex.com, it
would appear directly after losing the court
battle all his companies had suddenly gone
completely bankrupt at the same time his own
personal finances also mysteriously went to
zero…
Although the court ordered Cohen to return
to the U.S. and show cause for his apparent
contempt, he ignored the order and remained
out of the country.
He did, however, briefly get arrested in Mexico
for trying to smuggle some money back into
America, but would state after being caught
that he’d simply been trying to pay back
Kremen as the court had ordered him too before
authorities got in the way…
The trial court then declared him a fugitive
from justice and an arrest warrant was issued,
but it couldn’t be served.
About this time, Kremen himself posted a “Wanted”
poster with a $50,000 reward on sex.com, which
only played into Cohen’s hands.
Cohen then claimed he not only couldn’t
return to the United States, but that the
arrest warrant should be rescinded because
between that and the reward for his capture,
the authorities and bounty hunters outside
of his Mexico residence were allegedly engaging
in gunfights to see who would apprehend him
– which posed a threat to his and other
lives.
The trial court was nonplussed and refused
his request.
Cohen managed to keep himself out of the reach
of U.S. authorities for about five years,
despite, according to Kremen, regularly still
calling to taunt him over the sex.com heist
and even once offering Kremen shares in the
controversial file sharing system Earthstation
5 Cohen helped found.
Naturally, Kremen had no interest in taking
stock in one of Cohen’s companies over actual
money.
Things changed when Cohen was arrested in
2005 in Mexico for violating immigration laws.
You see, Kremen had discovered that Cohen
had divorced his wife, Rosa, which meant he
needed a different visa to stay there.
Naturally, Kremen made this fact known to
U.S. Marshals, once of which chose to pursue
the matter, resulting in Cohen being arrested
when he attempted to acquire said correct
visa in person.
You see, when standing in the immigration
office, Cohen didn’t yet have the visa,
so was officially in violation of Mexican
immigration laws and in a location authorities
knew he’d show up at.
And so it was that he was shipped back to
the United States where he spent a surprisingly
short time in prison before being released
on December 5, 2006.
So Kremen finally got some of that money,
right?
Nope, Cohen claimed poverty and backed it
up with documentation showing he had no assets
or money to speak of.
Of course, sifting through the massive paper
trail of at least 12 companies around the
world and various individuals, including family
members, Cohen seems to have used to hide
some pretty massive sums of money after his
sex.com escapade, the courts weren’t, and
aren’t, buying it.
At least as recently as 2011, which is the
last court rulings we could find connected
to the case, the matter was still ongoing,
with some of the bank accounts of said people
closely connected to Cohen, and containing
some rather enormous sums of money, having
been frozen.
In terms of whether Kremen would actually
ever get access to the many millions of dollars
in said frozen accounts, let alone the millions
more Cohen is thought to have stashed around
in unknown accounts, this is still up in the
air.
But Kremen states he told Cohen during one
of the conversations he’s had with him when
Cohen calls to taunt, “I tell him it’s
going to happen with or without lube, so lie
down and get it over with…”
To date, however, he’s still waiting on
the now over $80 million owed here including
interest.
But don’t feel too bad for Kremen.
You see, beyond eventually getting to run
his own version of sex.com, making a cool
half a million dollars per month from it before
the dot.com bubble burst, and later selling
it for $14 million in 2006 ($17.5 million
today), there was still the matter of Network
Solutions who had transferred ownership of
his very valuable property without ever notifying
him in any way they were doing this.
Thus, he set his sites on Network Solutions
and its parent company, VeriSign, who acquired
Network Solutions for a whopping $21 billion
in 2000.
He alleged four causes of action in this particular
law suit, including breach of contract and
conversion (taking someone’s property).
The trial court rejected the breach of contract
claims because Kremen never paid for the domain
name registration (again, back then you could
register for free thanks to the National Science
Foundation), so there was no “consideration,”
that is, something of value Kremen paid in
exchange for the domain name.
This was upheld on appeal.
Network Solutions also argued, with some success
initially, that it was akin to a phone company,
with domain names essentially being phone
numbers.
As a lawyer for Network Solutions, Phil Sbarbaro,
stated, “A domain name is not property,
it’s a service.”
However, the trial court’s rejection of
the conversion claim was overturned by the
Court of Appeals.
The Ninth Circuit noted that while traditionally
the tort of conversion only applied to tangible
items (like a car), but not intangible things
(like information or the right to enforce
a license or registration), this was an old-fashioned
view of property and its value; accordingly,
the appellate court reversed the trial court’s
rejection and returned the claim, ruling that
Network Solutions was indeed liable for damages
here owing to having transferred ownership
of property without any authorization.
This was a landmark case as, from a legal
perspective, many of the laws pertaining to
real property now applied to domains, finally
affording domain owners some concrete legal
protections concerning their property.
Within a year, Kremen and VeriSign settled
the claim, reportedly for an amount in excess
of $15 million ($20.5 million today).
Then, of course, there was the matter of Kremen’s
sale of jobs.com, housing.com, autos.com,
sex.net, computer.com, a sale of a patent
he held for dynamic web pages for a cool $1.25
million, and money made from several companies
he created and sold in the last few decades.
On top of that, Cohen’s former 8,900 square
foot mansion in Rancho Sante Fe that was awarded
to Kremen, which he lived in for a time, sold
for $4 million in 2009.
He also has variously been awarded other bits
and pieces of Cohen’s assets when they can
be tracked down and after lengthy legal battles
in which Cohen does everything possible to
drag things out as long as he can.
On that note, Kremen has stated he’s not
yet gotten enough back in said liquid assets
to pay his legal fees (in excess of $5 million)
throughout the saga.
More recently, Kremen’s taken to investing
in dozens of renewable energy startups.
So ya, financially, he’s doing alright despite
not having the $65 million plus interest Cohen
owes him.
By all accounts the two still semi-regularly
converse though, generally in the form of
taunting one another over the latest events
in their joined, sordid saga.
Money isn’t everything and despite his enormous
success over the years, Kremen was still in
search of love well over a decade after getting
fed up with 900 number dating services and
deciding to found Match.com to solve the problem
for people such as himself.
As you might imagine, as a very rich bachelor
in Southern California, particularly one who
used to own and run a quasi-porn site in sex.com,
he had little trouble finding women wanting
to spend as much time with him as he liked.
But by his mid 40s, fed up with that lifestyle,
and instead wanting someone who’d love him
for him and not the size of his wallet, he
offered his friends a deal- if one of them
could find him a wife, he’d give said finder
and family an all expense paid trip to Hawaii.
This actually worked and he was introduced
to one Dr. Petia Atanassova, who became Petia
Kremen when they got married in 2008…
Unfortunately it would appear according to
court records that on January 29, 2014, the
couple filed for divorce, though the case
is still ongoing over four years later…
But there too, it’s not all bad news, he
did have two great kids in the interim.
And speaking of kids, while he might not have
made much money off of Match.com, thanks to
it, Kremen has boasted he was able to help
make over a million babies… indirectly of
course.
As previously noted, Companies in the early
1990s were often so ignorant of the internet
as a whole, let alone its potential as a tool
for advertising, sales and PR, that in the
latter days of 1993 about half of all Fortune
500 companies had failed to even register
their own name online.
Companies started to cotton on to the value
of domain names and the internet in the latter
days of 1994 when a writer for Wired magazine
called Joshua Quittner registered McDonalds.com
and, in a fascinating time capsule of an article,
jokingly mentioned he might try to sell McDonalds.com
to Burger King.
Before registering the domain, Quittner repeatedly
reached out to McDonald’s to politely inform
them that the domain was available and they
needed to grab it quickly before someone else
did.
At Quittner’s urging, Jane Hulbert of McDonald’s
media relations discussed the matter with
higher ups in the company.
The result?
Hulbert stated her superiors’ reaction to
her queries about McDonald’s plans concerning
the internet and the McDonald’s domain name
was, “No one seems to know anything about
[the internet]…”
Quittner ultimately decided to just register
McDonalds.com himself, even though it wasn’t
yet clear from a legal standpoint if this
constituted trademark infringement or not,
something that was at the time still being
fleshed out in court.
(He did ultimately give the domain to McDonald’s
after the company agreed to provide free high-speed
internet to a public school in Brooklyn.)
Quittner likewise reached out to Burger King
encouraging them to register BurgerKing.com
before someone else did.
He stated Burger King’s initial response
when he mentioned the internet was, “[Is
that] some kind of information thing, like
Prodigy?”